كشف البيت الابيض عن التزامات استثماريه
وصفقات مع دول الافريقيه تعزيزا لشراكه
بين الولايات المتحده ودول القاره وفي اول
قمه افريقيه امريكيه في عهد بايدن ووسط
وعود بدعم تمثيل القاره في مجموعه العشرين
قال الرئيس الامريكي جوبا ايضا ان تطوير
البنيه تحتيه في افريقيا ضروريه لبناء
اقتصاد عالميا قوي
ات الدوليه الامريكيه ستستثمر نحو 370
مليون دولار في مشاريع جديده منها 100
مليون لتامين الطاقه النظيفه
الصحراء و 20 مليون لاقتناء الاسمده لصغار
المزارعين ناسيه من نساء منهم 10 ملايين
دولار لدعم شركات صغيره متوسطه وتوفر مياه
الشرب لتجمعاته سكانيه محرومه من هذا
المورد
انا برايزز كما قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لوردس 8 الصين وروسيا توسعاني نفوذهما في
افريقيا بشكل متواصل واتهم البلدين بعدم
الشفافي
ين الشعبيه
في افريقيا وبينما يفعلون ذلك فهما ايضا
يوزعون تاثيرهم والاقتصادي والنقطه
المثيره للقلق هنا انهم لا يبتسمون
بالشفافيه دائما فيما يتعلق بما يقومون به
وهذا يخلق مشاكل ستؤدي في النهايه الى
زعزعه الاستقرار هذا اذا لم يكن ذلك قد
حصل بالفعل